[Música]
el congreso peruano vota Este martes el
proyecto para adelantar las elecciones
entre tanto amnistía internacional envió
un equipo al país para investigar las
denuncias de violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos analizamos Cuál será el
desarrollo y proceder de esta misión
el canciller Alemán olapsol se reunió
con el presidente brasileño Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva como parte de su gira
latinoamericana ambos mandatarios
condenaron la invasión rusa de Ucrania y
comentaron planes para buscar la paz
Lula reiteró su apoyo al acuerdo entre
la Unión Europea y el mercosur que se
encuentra bloqueado ampliamos desde Río
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos condenó al Estado colombiano por
el Exterminio sistemático en los años 80
de los integrantes de La Unión
patriótica un partido político de
izquierda el hecho que contó con el
apoyo de las autoridades fue calificado
como crimen de lesa humanidad
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos este Informativo en
Perú en donde el congreso debatirá Este
martes el proyecto con el que se busca
adelantar las elecciones generales para
este año 2023 después de aceptar
debatirlo de esta manera se daría
respuesta a uno de los principales
reclamos de los ciudadanos en las calles
la presidenta Dina boluarte reiteró su
llamado al legislativo para que ayude a
desbloquear la crisis política a través
de la aprobación del proyecto el informe
es de Marina sardinha
en contra 66 votos a favor 49 en contra
y seis abstenciones señores congresistas
ha sido aprobada la reconsideración a la
votación del texto sustitutorio El
Congreso peruano aprobó así reconsiderar
la votación del proyecto de reforma
constitucional que permitiría el
adelanto de los comicios generales a
octubre de 2023 Pese a que el pasado
viernes un desacreditado legislativo
rechazó por amplia mayoría esta
propuesta en un intercambio de
apelaciones la criticada presidenta
dinable pidió al congreso que asuma su
responsabilidad histórica Y responde al
grito de las miles de personas que
continúan saliendo a las calles de todo
el país voten por el Perú a favor del
país
adelantando las elecciones al 2023 y
digámosle al Perú entero con la más alta
responsabilidad que nos vamos todos el
consejo permanente de la organización de
los Estados Americanos aprobó una
declaración sobre los hechos que se
sucediendo en Perú la oea mostró su
preocupación por las denuncias sobre el
uso excesivo de la fuerza y la represión
por parte de los uniformados para callar
el estallido social haciendo un llamado
a las autoridades peruanas para la
realización de elecciones generales uno
de los principales pedidos de los
manifestantes su firma llamado a las
autoridades peruanas para que aseguren
la gobernabilidad e institucionalidad
democrática mediante la pronta
realización de elecciones generales
justas libres y transparentes con
observación electoral internacional la
convocatoria de elecciones se antoja
como una de las principales vías para
desescalar la crisis política y social
que vive la nación andina desde
diciembre cuando la destitución del ex
mandatario Pedro Castillo o de un
intento fallido de golpe de estado sacó
a las calles a miles de peruanos en
medio de esta convulsa situación
política y social en Perú la
organización amnistía internacional
decidió enviar un equipo al país para
investigar las violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos anteriormente pudimos
hablar con Marina Navarro ejecutiva de
amnistía internacional en Perú que nos
contaba qué va a hacer concretamente
este equipo pues este equipo lo que va a
hacer es recabar toda la información
hacer una investigación recabando Pues
los testimonios de las personas de las
víctimas de los familiares de los
fallecidos también del de Testigos que
han estado para recabar información
sobre posibles responsabilidades de
crimen de derecho internacional que
pudieran llegar a tener las autoridades
entonces lo que quiere hacer realmente
es reforzar todo el trabajo que ya hemos
visto del uso excesivo de la fuerza y
tener una investigación in situ en los
lugares donde ha ocurrido para poder
reforzar la investigación Esta visita Es
realmente clave Porque además lo que
queremos hacer es llegar a los lugares
estamos hablando que ha habido real
muchos muertos 11 en ayacucho seis en
andahuaylas prácticamente 20 en Entonces
es importante llegar a los lugares donde
esto ha ocurrido Y lamentablemente
también uno no quiere dejar de decirlo
en en Lima este este sábado pasado
Entonces es bien importante que se pueda
recabar ahí toda la información que hay
y también una respuesta a las
autoridades que hasta ahora no están
teniendo una rendición de cuentas desde
amnistía internacional estamos pidiendo
el cese inmediato del uso excesivo de la
fuerza que tantas vidas se está llevando
en el Perú y que tan lleno se está
dejando los hospitales de heridos que
estamos hablando de más de 1.200 heridos
en durante estas fuertes represiones que
hemos visto por parte de las fuerzas del
orden
el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da silvalle el canciller Alemán
holapsol se reunieron en Brasilia un
encuentro que hace parte de la gira del
canciller alemán por Argentina chile y
Brasil nos ampliaba previamente desde
río nuestra corresponsal Valeria
hoy el presidente Lula bromeado con el
canciller olafls recordando aquella
Trágica derrota de Brasil contra
Alemania el famoso 7-1 en los mundiales
de 2014 antes de abordar los temas
importantes del día sin duda el
principal es el acuerdo comercial entre
el mercosur y la Unión Europea que había
quedado congelado durante el gobierno de
Jair bolsonaro Lula ha anunciado que ya
en julio de este año se podría alcanzar
el tan esperado acuerdo comercial
también se ha hablado y mucho de medio
ambiente porque Alemania es uno de los
países europeos que más dinero aporta al
fondo amazonía que había quedado también
de nuevo suspendido al principio del
gobierno de bolsonaro debido a las dudas
que tenían los gobernantes europeos
sobre las reales intenciones de
bolsonaro de preservar la amazonía y
evitar la deforestación sabemos que
Alemania podría aportar hasta 200
millones de euros no solo amazonia pero
también para realizar otro tipo de
acciones medioambientales en Brasil y
finalmente también se ha abordado el
espinoso asunto de la guerra entre Rusia
y Ucrania Lula ha dicho que Rusia es sin
duda culpable de la invasión del
territorio Pro ha recordado que dos no
pelean si uno no quiere una forma de
responsabilizar al gobierno ucraniano de
la situación actual y ha propuesto crear
un grupo de países para intentar mediar
un acuerdo de paz
la Corte Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos condenó al Estado colombiano por
el Exterminio de los integrantes del
partido político de izquierdas la unión
patriótica la persecución y represión de
la que fue víctima esta formación
política dejó unas 6.000 personas
muertas por lo que la sentencia que
califica el hecho como un crimen de lesa
humanidad es histórica en Colombia Esta
es su historia
[Aplausos]
se trató de un Exterminio político ante
los ojos de un país entero la historia
del partido de la unión patriótica up de
lata parte de la crueldad de la
violencia vivida en Colombia a finales
del siglo XX el partido nació en 1985
producto de unas negociaciones entre la
extinta guerrilla de las FARC y el
gobierno del expresidente colombiano
Belisario Betancourt su bandera Amarilla
simbolizaba un deseo convertir al
partido en una alternativa en un
escenario político dominado por décadas
por dos partidos tradicionales el
liberal y el conservador su conformación
se convirtió en una tercera vía y fue
vista como una posibilidad de
representación política para una parte
del electorado a la vez buscaba ser un
mecanismo de transición de las armas a
la política de las Farc
en 1986 consiguieron 15 escaños en el
congreso
pero su proyecto quedó inconcluso por el
asesinato de sus representantes año tras
año la violencia fue perpetrada por
grupos paramilitares una alianza con
sectores de la política tradicional la
fuerza pública y grupos empresariales
así lo anunciaba su líder en los años 90
desde luego que nosotros sabemos muy
bien cómo son las conexiones de estos
grupos con con autoridades y con la
propios sectores de la inteligencia
militar una violencia con enormes
dimensiones que incluso cobró la vida de
dos candidatos presidenciales en 2002 el
Consejo Nacional electoral le retiró la
personería jurídica al no conseguir
escaños suficientes una decisión
cuestionada solo entre 1984 y 2002 según
cifras del observatorio de memoria y
conflicto más de 3000 de sus miembros
fueron asesinados
hasta este lunes sólo 219 víctimas eran
reconocidas oficialmente por el estado
colombiano y su responsabilidad era solo
vista de manera indirecta ahora
condenado el estado de braz al dar parte
de su deuda histórica con sus familiares
y sobrevivientes
en Venezuela cientos de trabajadores
públicos en su mayoría del sector
educativo salieron de nuevo a las calles
a protestar por sus bajos salarios las
manifestaciones que comenzaron con
protestas gremiales se extienden ya por
tres semanas exigiendo que sus salarios
se equiparen al menos al precio de la
canasta básica que con la devaluación
del Bolívar en diciembre alcanzó los 485
dólares para una familia de 5 miembros
según estimaciones independientes
[Música]
está aquí las noticias sigan conectados
a France 24
[Música]